let's go next to our caller from the 706
area code 706 what's your name where you
calling from oh that is you all right my
name is Mike I'm calling from Georgia
what's going on Mike
all right I have one question and maybe
a second if I have time are you aware of
this Bernie Sanders quote that came from
20 I think it was a 2015 interview with
NBC where he was talking about how you
don't need like 23 brands of deodorant
or sneakers when there's children
starving or are you aware of that quote
I you know it rings a bell but I
honestly if you said if you had just
given me the quote and said who said it
I don't know that I would say it was
Bernie so I mean I'm generally aware
that I guess someone said that but I
don't know for sure who or if it's
accurately attributed to Bernie oh it
was there's like an interview with
believe it was NBC them harwood I think
it's his name okay I was just wondering
you know he's gotten a lot of flack for
it Bernie has in like libertarian
circles do you think it's a legitimate
criticism or do you think that there's
you know something that not being said I
mean what so the the the crux of for
someone to say Americans don't need
twenty three types of deodorant when
kids in Africa are starving is sort of
like saying you know you can't you'd
better eat you'd better clean your
entire plate in Boston Massachusetts
because there are kids in Africa
starving which is I understand the
sentiment which is we you know there are
first world problems and then there are
people living in abject poverty and we
should all act thoughtfully to the
extent that we can and be activists for
improving the world for as many people
as possible I get that but from strictly
speaking it's it's sort of a fallacy in
a sense I mean that so I don't it's not
how I would make the case for activism
let me put it that way okay okay I can
believe that makes sense
all right well second
question I had about birdies free
college plan okay I'm big supporter
Bernie
by the way this is in no way a criticism
of Bernie I'm a huge very supporter okay
I had a conversation with libertarian
friend of mine about Bernie's a free
college plan and he was talking about
how a free college would control what
gets taught in school do you know if
that's true I cannot imagine how you
strongly make that case no I mean I'm
sure that if you asked exactly how that
would happen I guess the idea would be
if college is paid through taxation then
the government can tell the colleges
what they need to teach but it's like I
don't believe that that is what would
happen and there's the potential for
that to already happen because there are
so many schools that are already funded
by state governments if not federal so
it seems like an extremely weak argument
against Bernie's plan but you'd have to
find out exactly how they imagined it
would go down okay yeah I've been doing
research and I've been really finding
nothing to back that argument like I've
searched deep in the internet I just I
came up empty
yep well I mean I'm certainly not aware
of how you would defend such an such an
assertion yeah okay well that's all I
had okay thank you appreciate the phone
call great to hear from you